foreign [Music]
CBS deals and this morning we have three products
that may give you a reason to stay in bed and
pamper yourself especially on these kind of
cold nights it's all they are all at exclusive
low prices so to start shopping now scan the
QR code on your screen or visit cbsdeals.com
lifestyle expert Ashley Bellman joins us more and
we are going to be warm I am so happy that we have
this product this is the calming heat sauna wrap
I'm just going to get right in it if you don't
mind because it's very cold here today this is
just like a sleeping bag you jump in it put it
on your bed any flat heat resistant service
oh thank you yeah get in with me it's so warm
[Music] it's really warm it's warm it vibrates
you can control it with the remote 179.99 today
at cbsdeals.com 40 off my mom I told her I was
get I was doing this today she couldn't believe
it she's been looking for something like this
because she has problem sweating she's like you
know how important sweating is to detox the body
burns calories and I don't know about you but I
enjoy burning calories laying down very nice it's
40 off this is something that is going to warm
you up it's the infrared heat it's the vibrations
it's just all around good and it feels nice to be
warm and it will shut off after 30 minutes if you
oh that's that's key yes you have something else
for the bed something else in the bed okay this
is called better better so I always sleep better
I'll get this you go down oh thank you I always
sleep better in hotels and I think it's because
it's the perfectly made bed all the sheets are
tucked in so nicely so this is a headband it goes
around the back said king or queen starting at
23.99 you tuck the fitted or the flat sheet into
it and it's going to give you that perfectly made
bed always and then at night when you're sleeping
is going to stay nice and tucked also I love that
I can put on the side my Kindle which always gets
lost in the bed I'm always yelling at my husband
accusing him of stealing it when he did nothing
the remote it's the remote the glasses the perfect
Hospital Corner what more can you have exactly no
right then and 40 off again king or queen size
this is something no excuse for not being able
to make the bed anymore well what do we have here
okay so from blast Beauty we have the Smart Eye
massager the eye mask that's only 9.99 55 is the
savings today you put that on to protect your eye
makeup and then put the eye massager over there's
different settings it's going to oscillate it's
going warm it's going to de-puff de-stress get you
ready for bed get you early in the morning or for
the morning and if maybe you look at a screen all
day this is the perfect solution right it's good
good and then you also have the blast Beauty
balm which is vegan cruelty free this really
great formula 19.99 for the balm it's a stick
you can use it to even out your uneven skin
tones this is like the go-to anything you need
bomb does it hydrate hydrates all the good stuff
and I love that it's so easy it's so compact take
it with you anywhere use it all in combination so
put it on put on the mask and then put on the
massager or use them one by one but 19.99 the
mass 9.99 this is 76 55 off cbsdeals.com like
those percentages off Ashley as always thank
you of course of course we partner with all of
these companies to get these deals so to buy
anything you saw today just scan that QR code
on your screen or head on over to cbsdeals.com